in an experiment aimed at studying the
effect of advertising on eating behavior
in children a group of 500 children 7 to
11 years old were randomly assigned to
two different groups after randomization
each child was asked to watch the
cartoon in a private room containing a
bowl a large bowl of goldfish crackers
the cartoon included two commercial
breaks the first group watched food
commercials mostly sacks while the
second group watched non-food
commercials games and entertainment
products once the child finished
watching the cartoon the conductors of
the experiment weighed the cracker bowls
to measure how many grams of crackers
the child ate they found that the mean
amount of crackers eaten by the children
who watched food commercials is 10 grams
greater than the mean amount of crackers
eaten by the children who watched
non-food commercials so let's just think
about what happens up up to this point
so they took 500 they took 500 children
and then they randomly assign them to
two different groups so you have Group 1
over here and you have group 2 so let's
say that this right over here is the
first group the first group watched food
commercials so this is group number 1 so
they watched food commercials we could
call this the treatment group we're
trying to see what's the effect of
watching food commercials and then they
tell us the second group the second
group watched non-food commercials so
this is the control group so number two
this is non-food commercials so this is
the control right over here once the
child finished watching the cartoon they
weighed how much the meet they for each
child they weighed how much of the
crackers they ate and then they took the
the mean of it and they found that the
mean here that the kids ate 10 grams
greater on average then this group right
over here which just looking at that
data makes you believe that okay well
something maybe happened over here that
then maybe the treatment from watching
the food commercials made the students
eat more of the of the goldfish crackers
but the question that you always have to
ask yourself in a situation like this
well is it there's some probability that
this would have happened by chance that
even if you did
if you didn't make them watch the
commercials if this if these were just
two random groups and you didn't make
either group watch a commercial you made
them all watch the same commercials
there's some chance that the mean of one
group could be dramatically different
than the other one it just happened to
be in this experiment that the mean here
that it looks like the kids ate 10 grams
more so how do you figure out what's the
probability that this could have
happened that this could have that that
the that the 10 grams greater and mean
amount eaten here that that could have
just happened by chance
well the way you do it is what they do
right over here using a simulator
they re randomized they re randomized
the results into two new groups and
measure the difference between the means
of the new groups they repeated the
simulation 150 times and plotted the
differences given the results the
resulting differences as given below so
what they did is they said okay they
have 500 kids and each kid they had 500
children so number 1 2 3 all the way up
to 500 all the way up to 500 and for
each child they measured how much was
the weight of the crackers that they ate
so maybe child 1 8 2 grams and child 2 8
4 grams and child 3 8 I don't know 8 12
grams all the way to child number 508 I
don't know maybe they didn't eat
anything at all 8 0 grams and we already
know let's say you know the first time
around 1 1 through 201 through I guess
we should you know the the first half
was in the treatment group when they
were when we're just ranking them like
this and then the second they were
randomly assigned into these groups and
then the second half was in the control
group but what they're doing now is
they're taking the same results and
their rear and amaizing it so now
they're saying ok let's maybe put this
person in then group number 2 put and
this person in group number 2 and this
person stays in group number 2 and this
person stays in group number 1 and this
person stays in group number 1 so now
they're completely mixing up all of the
results that they had so
it's completely random of whether the
student had watched the food commercial
or the non-food commercial and then
they're testing what's the mean what's
the mean of the new number one group and
the new number two group and then
they're saying well what what is the
distribution of the differences in means
so they see when they did it this way
when they're essentially just completely
randomly taking these results and
putting them into two new buckets you
have a bunch of cases where you get no
difference in the mean so out of the 100
out of the hundred 50 times that they
repeated the simulation doing this
little exercise here 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 tribal counting this
is see 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
oh I don't want to keep it so small I'm
having them aging but it looks like
there's about you know I don't know high
teens about 20 times when there was
actually no noticeable difference in the
means of the groups where you just
randomly when you just randomly allocate
the results amongst the two groups so
when you look at this if it was just you
know if you just randomly put people
into two groups the probability or the
the situations where you get a 10 a 10
gram difference is are actually very
unlikely so this is let's see is this
the difference the difference between
the means of the new groups so it's not
clear whether this is group 1 minus
group 2 or group 2 minus group 1 but in
either case the situations where you
have a 10 where you have a 10 gram
difference in mean it's only two out of
the hundred and fifty times so when you
do it randomly when you you know when
you just randomly put these results into
two groups the probability of the means
being this different it only happens to
out of the hundred and fifty times
there's 150 dots here so that is on the
order of of two percent or actually it's
less than two percent it's between one
and two percent and if you know that you
know this is group let's say let's say
that the situation we're talking about
let's say that this is Group 1 minus
group 2
in terms of how much was eaten and so
you're looking at this situation right
over here then that's only one out of
150 times so it's it happened less than
what it happened it happened less
frequently than one in a hundred times
it happened only one in a hundred and
fifty times so if you look at that you
say well the probability of this was
just random the probability of getting
the results that you got is less than
one percent so to me and then to most
statisticians that tells us that our
experiment was significant that the
probability of getting the results that
you got so the children who watched food
commercials being 10 grams greater than
the mean amount of crackers eaten by the
children who watched non-food
commercials if you just randomly put 500
kids into two different buckets based on
the simulation results it looks like
there's only there's there's only if
you'd run the simulation 150 times that
only happened one out of 150 times so it
seems like this was very it's very
unlikely that this was purely due to
chance if there's this if this was just
a chance event this would only happen
what roughly one in 150 times but the
fact that this happened in your
experiment makes you feel pretty
confident that your experiment is
significant in most in most studies and
most experiments the threshold that they
think about is the probability of
significant if the probability of that
happening by chance is less than five
percent so this is less than one percent
so I would definitely say that the
experiment is significant